Joker how are you gonna make it through
the finals where you look like you can
barely make it through a Burger King
drive-through
this is what we want this is America yes
keep going
yo kids I love your game
[Applause]
I barely make it through a Burger King
drive through you shouldn't be on the
court you should be checking IDs outside
of a hookah bar you gotta say it like
that
all right let's keep going let's keep
giving these people this work Kevin
Durant let's go
[Laughter]
you keep joining super teams to win the
NBA title how about how about we work
out together sometimes so I can teach
you how to carry your own team
you know what I'm saying like I like
that one it was like a little simpler
KD where's the camera KD you're one of
the best scorers in this game
I respect your day you know you've lead
by example for 15 years
so I hate this you were my favorite
player growing up I hate this entertain
me I respect your game
I'm sorry no no no
[Music]
I do the LeBron one we're gonna get out
of here but make this one cow
LeBron
I love your game man
[Applause]
[Music]
goat just broke the all-time
um score in uh record keep doing what
you're doing man uh
he's a blueprint you're a blueprint man
[Applause]
all right all right listen listen man
um everybody we talked about in the NBA
uh please don't come kill me